Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder:
Bonjour et bienvenue
dans "Parlement hebdo",
l'émission
qui revient sur l'actualité
parlementaire
à l'Assemblée
nationale et au Sénat.
On parlera du projet
de loi immigration.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Nous accueillons Yan Chantrel.
Vous êtes sénateur socialiste
des Français établis
hors de France.
- Kathia Gilder:
La loi immigration
a été adoptée et votée
avec les voix
de la droite, celles
du Rassemblement National,
mais pas par toute la majorité.
L'exécutif se défend
de toute crise politique
malgré la démission d'un ministre.
On verra ce que contient
cette nouvelle loi immigration:
instauration de quotas,
prestations sociales
sous conditions,
plusieurs dispositions ajoutées
par la droite sénatoriale
changent profondément
le droit des étrangers.
Certaines dispositions
pourraient
être retoquées par le Conseil
constitutionnel,
au nom du principe
d'égalité,
parce qu'elles n'ont rien à faire
dans la loi.
Les sages ont un mois
pour se prononcer.
- Alexandre Poussart:
L'Assemblée nationale
a adopté mardi le projet de loi
immigration issu
de la commission
mixte paritaire,
un vote qui a divisé
la majorité présidentielle,
indigné la gauche et réjoui
Les Républicains
et le Rassemblement National.
- La loi immigration votée mardi,
l'épilogue d'une séquence
politique qui va laisser
des traces.
Premier pilier ébranlé:
la majorité.
- Sur ce texte,
il y a des lignes rouges.
- Avec 189 pour,
27 contre et 32 abstentions,
c'est près d'un quart
des députés
de la majorité
qui a refusé de soutenir
le texte issu de la commission
mixte paritaire.
Une fracture
qui aurait pu
être plus profonde
si le gouvernement
n'avait pas annoncé
qu'il exclurait les voix
du Rassemblement National
du résultat.
- Il n'y aura pas de texte
s'il n'y a pas de majorité
sans le Rassemblement National!
- Un Rassemblement National
qui clame pourtant
sa victoire.
- Vos sénateurs RN ont voté
contre le texte
du Sénat voilà un mois.
Désormais,
c'est le texte du Sénat
et vous votez pour!
- Qu'importe, pour Marine Le Pen.
- On peut tout de même
se réjouir d'une victoire,
même idéologique,
du Rassemblement National,
puisque est écrite
dans cette loi
la priorité nationale.
- La droite
a également revendiqué
sa victoire.
C'est une version proche
de celle adoptée
par le Sénat qui a été adoptée.
- Un chemin a été ouvert.
Il a été ouvert
très clairement
par Les Républicains.
Nous avions dit
que nous voulions
ce texte, il est là.
- La gauche aura en vain
appelé la majorité
à renoncer.
- Tout ce que vous aviez tenu
pour des lignes rouges
a été transgressé.
Vous franchissez désormais
des lignes bleues marines.
- Des concessions
qui auront marqué
des compromissions indélébiles.
- Kathia Gilder:
Yan Chantrel, 25%
des députés
de la majorité
n'ont pas voté la loi immigration.
Est-ce que pour vous,
c'est la fin
du macronisme tel qu'il existe?
- Yan Chantrel:
Oui, c'est la fin
du "en même temps".
Le seul mandat
réel du président
de la République,
c'est qu'il a été élu
pour faire barrage
à l'extrême droite.
Il reprend le programme
historique
du Rassemblement National,
du Front National,
à travers
les différentes mesures,
dont la déchéance
de nationalité,
ce que le président
de la République
avait combattu.
Il perd un quart de sa majorité.
Elle se rétrécit de plus en plus.
Il avait déjà
un gouvernement minoritaire.
On a l'impression
d'être dans une fin
de règne,
alors qu'il y a encore
plus de trois ans
de mandat devant nous.
Quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter?
Quand est-ce
qu'il va continuer à aller
dans un puits sans fond?
Ca montre ce qu'est le macronisme.
Il n'y a pas de colonne
vertébrale.
C'est juste
de l'opportunisme politique.
Il y a des personnes au sein
de ce gouvernement
qui se disent
avoir appartenu,
à une époque, à la gauche,
et qui acceptent
une loi que je qualifie
de scélérate.
- Kathia Gilder:
Et qui l'ont votée.
- Yan Chantrel:
Oui, et qui restent
en poste.
Quand on a réellement
des convictions humanistes,
qu'on considère
qu'il y a un cap
qui a été franchi
de la part du gouvernement
et de la présidence
de la République,
on va vers un puits sans fond
de l'extrême droite.
C'est pour ça que l'ensemble
des partis
de gauche
et des syndicats demande
au président
de la République de renoncer
à cette loi
qui a été adoptée
et de la retirer.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Le président
de la République estime
que ce texte immigration,
c'est un bouclier
qui permettrait
de mieux lutter
contre le Rassemblement National.
Est-ce qu'un texte ferme
sur l'immigration,
ça peut faire baisser le RN?
- Yan Chantrel:
Ce qui fait baisser
le RN,
ce n'est pas de reprendre
sa politique.
Ce qu'on souhaite, à gauche,
c'est favoriser l'intégration.
C'était aussi
dans l'intitulé
de ce texte, à la base.
Il faut la favoriser au maximum.
Il n'y a pas une seule
des dispositions
qui sont prises
qui la favorisent,
au contraire.
C'est l'inverse.
Quand vous empêchez
le regroupement familial,
vous ne favorisez pas
l'intégration.
- Kathia Gilder:
Le gouvernement martèle
le contraire.
Elisabeth Borne dit
qu'il y a des mesures
pour mieux intégrer.
- Yan Chantrel:
On les a cherchées
à la loupe.
Il n'y a pas grand-chose,
voire rien
du tout.
- Kathia Gilder:
Ce n'est pas suffisant,
les cours de français?
- Yan Chantrel:
C'est une bonne chose,
mais ce n'est pas grand-chose.
Par contre, les mesures
comme la restriction
de regroupement
familial,
ou encore la caution
pour les étrangers
ou les étudiants
étrangers,
c'est une catastrophe
pour le rayonnement
de notre pays.
C'est un texte
d'affaiblissement
dans notre pays.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous dites qu'un cap
a été franchi.
On est dans une crise
politique, pourtant,
un seul ministre n'a démissionné.
- Yan Chantrel:
Oui, et je salue
son courage, Aurélien Rousseau.
Il y a quand même
un ministre
qui a été courageux.
Contrairement à ce que dit
le gouvernement,
l'AME,
c'est la prochaine chose
qui est visée.
Je sais que la ministre
de l'Enseignement supérieur
a également proposé sa démission.
On n'a pas besoin de la proposer.
On n'a pas besoin
de demander l'autorisation.
Je pense qu'elle aurait raison
de démissionner.
Au-delà des simples
démissions,
c'est le cap politique.
Il y a un changement
de cap politique
qui est à droite toute,
qui est dangereux.
Quelque part, on demande
au gouvernement
de se ressaisir.
-
Alexandre Poussart:
Est-ce que les députés
de gauche
ont une responsabilité
en ayant voté,
il y a 10 jours,
la motion de rejet
de ce texte immigration
à l'Assemblée nationale?
Il n'y a pas eu de débat,
et c'est donc
le texte plus dur
de la droite sénatoriale
qui a été imposé à la majorité.
- Yan Chantrel:
Il ne faut pas inverser
les responsabilités.
La gauche est contre ce texte.
Elle a acté le fait
qu'elle était contre.
Elle a adopté une motion de rejet.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Elle aurait pu
en débattre à l'Assemblée.
- Yan Chantrel:
On s'y est opposé
très fortement au Sénat.
Il y a une opposition
de la part
de la gauche
à l'Assemblée nationale,
qui ne voulait pas de ce texte.
Nous ne voulons pas
de ce texte
qui n'est pas équilibré.
L'Assemblée
nationale manifeste
son rejet.
Qu'aurait pu faire
le président
de la République?
Il aurait pu faire
une deuxième lecture,
il aurait pu apaiser le pays.
Ce texte
ne permet pas un rassemblement
suffisamment large.
- Kathia Gilder:
On vous entend bien,
mais il y a pourtant
70% de Français
qui voulaient ce texte.
Que dites-vous à cette opinion?
- Yan Chantrel:
Quand vous regardez
dans les détails,
il y a aussi 60%
des Français qui disent
ne pas connaître précisément
les enjeux qui sont liés
à l'immigration.
Ils ne connaissent pas
le nombre
de personnes
qui sont reçues réellement
chaque année.
Quand vous regardez,
plus les gens méconnaissent
le sujet,
plus ils y sont favorables.
C'est trompeur.
On verra
dans l'application,
ce que je ne souhaite pas,
puisque je souhaite
que le Conseil constitutionnel
revienne dessus,
mais dans le temps,
ça aura des effets
plus délétères qu'autre chose.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va d'ailleurs évoquer
le fond des mesures
qui ont été évoquées,
issues de la commission
mixte paritaire,
des mesures de fermeté
qui ont été ajoutées
par la droite du Sénat
qui a revendiqué
une victoire politique
sur la majorité présidentielle.
- Pour: 214.
Contre: 114.
Le Sénat a adopté
le projet de loi.
- Après l'accord
arraché par la droite
à l'exécutif,
c'est un texte durci
qui a été adopté.
Régularisation
au cas par cas
par les préfets
dans les métiers
en tension, fin
de l'automaticité
du droit du sol,
le patron des LR
s'en félicite.
- 80% des Français pensent
qu'il faut maîtriser
l'immigration,
qu'il y a trop d'immigration
en France.
C'est ce qui rassemble
les Français
de droite comme les Français
de gauche.
C'est un texte
de fermeté
qui est très proche
du texte du Sénat.
Mais soyons modestes.
Il n'y a qu'un seul texte.
- Le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin juge
les modifications
du Sénat mineures
par rapport au projet initial.
- Le texte du Sénat
n'est pas le texte
qui remplace le texte
du gouvernement,
mais qui le complète.
Sur 27 articles...
Sur 27 articles,
un seul a été retiré.
- Rétablissement du délit
de séjour irrégulier,
déchéance de nationalité
pour les binationaux coupables
d'homicide volontaire
sur les forces
de l'ordre, débat annuel
sur les quotas migratoires,
pour les centristes,
certaines mesures
étaient un mal nécessaire.
-
Je ne dis pas
que tout ce qui est voté
nous convient,
mais c'est le propre
des discussions
qui permettent de trouver
des compromis.
Sinon, il n'y
a pas de texte voté,
pas de majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale.
Il faut
que tout le monde fasse
des efforts.
- Sur la question
des aides sociales
qui a fait l'objet
d'un blocage
dès l'ouverture de la commission
mixte paritaire,
la mesure revient
avec une forme
de préférence nationale.
Le bénéfice de cette aide
personnalisée
au logement
est conditionné à cinq ans
de présence
sur le territoire
pour les étrangers
ne travaillant pas,
et à 30 mois pour les autres.
Sur l'aide
médicale d'Etat
qui a fait l'objet
d'âpres discussions,
elle a été maintenue
et le gouvernement
a promis de présenter
une réforme
de ce dispositif début 2024.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Certains parlaient
de la victoire
du Rassemblement National.
Au fond,
est-ce que les grands
gagnants,
ce ne sont pas Les Républicains?
- Yan Chantrel:
Non, je pense
qu'ils se trompent.
Ce texte, c'était
déjà une reprise
du programme.
On a dénoncé le fait
qu'on était déjà
dans une dérive majeure
avec une reprise
du programme de l'extrême droite.
Les LR ont repris
un texte au sein
du Sénat.
Après, ils votent
main dans la main
avec l'extrême droite
qui s'est reconnue
dans son programme.
- Kathia Gilder:
L'instauration
d'un délai de carence
pour le versement
de certaines
aides sociales,
c'est ce qui figure dans le texte.
C'est beaucoup critiqué,
mais il existe déjà
un conditionnement.
Par exemple,
la prime d'activité
a un délai de carence
de cinq ans,
qui a été instauré
sous François Hollande.
Quelle est la différence,
pour vous?
-
Yan Chantrel:
Ce n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose.
Il y a aussi l'aide sociale.
- Kathia Gilder:
Aide sociale non contributive.
- Yan Chantrel: Oui,
il y a des choses
qui touchent à nos socles.
Vous pensez qu'on intègre
bien des gens
quand on ne leur permet pas
de toucher
des aides
pour que ces gens-là
ne soient pas démunis?
Pouvoir intégrer
des gens,
c'est qu'ils puissent
vivre
sur notre sol avec décence.
C'est un point d'achoppement...
- Kathia Gilder:
Ca veut dire
que ces gens-là
ne pourraient pas vivre
avec décence?
- Yan Chantrel:
Vous pouvez
ne pas avoir de logement
décent,
être à la rue.
Et ce texte
d'hébergement d'urgence
est également restreint.
La problématique, c'est que...
Ce qu'il faut
voir,
c'est que c'est une rupture
d'égalité.
A mon avis, c'est un des points
d'achoppement,
il y en a d'autres, au niveau
du Conseil constitutionnel.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Il y a plein
de mesures qui ont été
vivement discutées
sur ce texte immigration.
Il y a une remise en question,
un durcissement
du droit du sol.
Un enfant de deux parents
étrangers n'aura
plus la nationalité
automatiquement
à ses 18 ans s'il
est né en France.
Il devra faire une demande
dès ses 16 ans.
Ca va changer quelque chose?
- Yan Chantrel:
Ce qu'il faut savoir,
c'est que c'est un cas
hors sujet
par rapport au texte.
J'espère
que ce sera censuré
par le Conseil constitutionnel.
Beaucoup de personnes
se disent:
"Ce n'est pas
grand-chose",
mais on est dans un Etat de droit.
A partir du moment
où vous ouvrez
la brèche, après,
d'autres gouvernements
encore moins bien
intentionnés pourront aller
plus loin.
- Kathia Gilder:
Marine Le Pen,
par exemple?
- Yan Chantrel: Tout à fait.
Elle est carrément contre.
Vous ouvrez une brèche.
C'est pour ça
que quand on est à la tête
d'un Etat,
il y a quand même un minimum
de vision à avoir par rapport
aux valeurs
qu'on souhaite avoir.
Cette valeur,
c'est une brèche par rapport
au droit du sol.
- Kathia Gilder:
Pourtant,
devant la représentation
nationale, Gérald Darmanin s'est
félicité d'un texte
historique
qui va permettre
plus de 10.000 régularisations
de travailleurs
sans-papiers
dans les secteurs en tension.
- Yan Chantrel:
Je ne vois pas sur quoi
il se base.
A partir
du moment
où c'est quelque chose
d'arbitraire
qui va être décidé
par les préfets,
comment peut-il
savoir d'avance
qu'il y aura autant
de régularisations?
Il peut donner
des consignes,
mais il y en a déjà.
Je ne vois pas ce que ça ajoute.
C'est la loi.
Quand on est parlementaire,
je ne souhaite
pas déléguer
à l'arbitraire ce genre
de choses.
C'est à nous de définir
des règles claires
pour permettre la régularisation.
- Kathia Gilder:
Aujourd'hui,
c'est le préfet qui décide
qui il régularise
ou pas.
- Yan Chantrel:
C'est un des problèmes
de notre pays
que toutes les questions
de régularisation
soient sous la forme
de l'arbitraire.
Les règles ne sont pas claires.
Elles sont compliquées.
C'est un véritable
parcours du combattant.
Rien n'est facilité
pour les personnes
qui sont sur notre sol.
C'est des files d'attente
pour des personnes
qui sont souvent
sur notre territoire
depuis de très nombreuses
années,
qui vivent souvent
des humiliations,
et en fonction
de certaines préfectures,
qui ont plus de chances
que d'autres...
Il faut faciliter
leur intégration
et ne pas tout faire
pour les empêcher.
On a tout intérêt
à leur faciliter
la vie pour qu'elles puissent
s'intégrer.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Dans ce texte,
il n'y a pas eu
de restriction du panier
de soins de l'aide
médicale d'Etat
pour les étrangers
en situation irrégulière.
C'était une mesure
de la droite sénatoriale
qui n'a pas été retenue.
Elisabeth Borne
a promis un texte
en janvier pour réformer l'aide
médicale d'Etat,
notamment sur la base
d'un rapport
qui ne propose pas de toucher
au panier
de soins, mais qui propose
qu'un étranger
sous OQTF n'ait pas accès
à cette AME.
Vous pourriez voter ce texte?
- Yan Chantrel:
C'est un profond scandale,
sur l'AME,
ce n'est pas en lien
avec l'immigration.
Il s'agit de santé publique.
C'est un dispositif
de santé publique.
Ce n'est pas pour rien
que le ministre
de la Santé a démissionné.
Lui-même venant
du monde médical,
il sait très bien
ce qu'il y a en jeu
derrière ça.
Les microbes,
ils n'ont pas de papiers.
On a tout intérêt
à soigner
le plus rapidement
possible,
et non pas dans l'urgence,
ce que souhaite
la droite: une aide
médicale d'urgence
si la personne
est au bord de la mort
et vient encombrer les urgences.
Mais pour bien
soigner les gens,
il faut les prendre
le plus tôt possible
pour que ça
ne devienne pas plus coûteux
et plus grave.
On a une obligation
de solidarité
par rapport aux personnes.
Notre pays a toujours considéré...
J'ai vécu
dans d'autres pays
qui n'ont pas cette conception.
Notre pays considère
que la santé
est un bien universel,
fondamental
au niveau de la dignité humaine.
Je pense que revenir
sur cette aide médicale d'Etat,
c'est toucher
à cette dignité humaine
et à cette évidence
de besoin d'aide
aux plus démunis.
Qu'elles aient
des papiers ou non,
il faut les soigner.
- Kathia Gilder:
Il y a une mesure
de déchéance
de nationalité
pour les binationaux
qui tuent des policiers.
Est-ce que ça vous choque?
- Yan Chantrel: Le problème,
c'est qu'en général,
on pourrait se dire
que ça fait sens.
Mais à partir du moment
où vous créez
une brèche, ça sera utilisé
pour d'autres choses.
Il est là, le danger.
A partir du moment
où vous considérez...
Moi-même, je suis binational.
Vous différenciez
donc deux types
de ressortissants
français:
ceux qui ont une autre
nationalité,
et ceux qui n'en ont qu'une.
Déjà, vous faites
une distinction
au sein de la communauté
nationale.
Ils doivent
être punis sévèrement
dans tous les cas,
mais quand vous faites
une brèche, comment
faire en sorte
que ça
ne soit pas utilisé
pour des délits de droit commun?
Il est là, le danger.
On ne peut pas s'amuser
à faire
des apprentis sorciers
pour soi-disant "flatter
un électorat
extrémiste",
parce que derrière,
il y a des choses beaucoup
plus graves
qui pourraient advenir.
- Alexandre Poussart:
La bataille
des parlementaires
de gauche
contre ce texte n'est pas finie.
Ils souhaitent une saisine
du Conseil constitutionnel.
Les sages vont être saisis
pour s'exprimer
sur la constitutionnalité
de cette loi immigration.
Le gouvernement
a déjà dit
qu'il était certain que certaines
mesures seraient retoquées
par ce Conseil constitutionnel.
A droite, au Sénat,
on espère
encore que cette loi
immigration
va être épargnée.
-
Je ne connais pas les décisions
du Conseil constitutionnel
à l'avance.
On peut penser que le Conseil
constitutionnel applique
le droit
et que le droit
n'étant pas une science
exacte, il pourrait
avoir des positions
qui évoluent
dans le temps.
Il n'est pas interdit
que le Conseil constitutionnel
se rappelle que le droit,
c'est aussi
le reflet d'une société.
L'immigration
est un problème,
une question que se posent
les Français,
et peut-être le Conseil
constitutionnel
va pouvoir aussi
le prendre en compte
dans ses décisions.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Selon vous,
quelles mesures de cette loi
immigration peuvent
être retoquées?
- Yan Chantrel:
il y a la restriction
du droit du sol,
il y a aussi la différenciation
pour l'accès
aux aides sociales
qui est une rupture
d'égalité
dans la loi.
Il y a aussi l'histoire
de la caution,
par rapport
aux étudiants étrangers,
et la remise en cause
du droit du sol.
C'est un ensemble
de paramètres qui,
logiquement,
parce qu'on a une Constitution,
et qui en est le garant?
Le président de la République.
Il a donné une interview
où il reconnaît lui-même
les problématiques.
Il ne devrait pas promulguer
une loi
qui n'est pas
constitutionnelle
alors qu'il doit garantir
cette constitutionnalité.
C'est un vrai problème
constitutionnel,
que le président
de la République ait
cette place.
Une partie de ce texte
ne sera pas constitutionnelle.
Ce n'est pas sérieux
vis-à-vis
de la responsabilité
du respect
de la Constitution.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous êtes sénateur socialiste.
Des départements
de gauche ont dit
qu'ils refuseraient
d'appliquer
les délais de carence
pour les aides sociales
des étrangers.
Est-ce que ce n'est pas
le rôle
des élus d'être exemplaires?
- Yan Chantrel:
Dans notre histoire,
ce sera un point
de basculement,
cette loi.
Il y a eu d'autres moments,
malheureusement,
dans l'histoire,
assez sombres,
où il y a eu des points
de basculement.
C'est tout à l'honneur
des élus
de ne pas accepter.
- Kathia Gilder:
Vous cautionnez
la désobéissance civile?
- Yan Chantrel: En quelque sorte.
Quand une loi est scélérate,
effectivement...
- Kathia Gilder:
Même dans un Etat
de droit où la loi
s'applique à tous?
- Yan Chantrel:
Ca fait partie de l'Etat
de droit aussi.
Nous saisissons le Conseil
constitutionnel.
Il faut aller jusqu'au bout.
Il faut attendre la décision.
Cette loi, elle n'apaise pas.
Elle clive.
Ce serait de la responsabilité
du président
de la République
de rassembler, d'apaiser,
et de revenir
sur certaines décisions.
Il a reconnu
que ce n'était pas
une bonne chose.
- Kathia Gilder:
Comment vous interprétez
ce double langage?
- Yan Chantrel:
C'est assez surprenant.
Il reconnaît
qu'il a fait adopter
un texte sur lequel
il reconnaît
que des dispositions
ne sont pas bonnes.
Qu'il revienne dessus!
- Alexandre Poussart:
Vous dites
que ce texte
n'apaise pas le pays,
pourtant, une majorité
de Français
était pour cette loi
immigration
avec un parlement bloqué.
Est-ce que la solution,
ce
n'est pas le référendum?
Ce n'est pas possible
sur l'immigration,
mais en ce moment,
vu le blocage
au niveau
parlementaire, est-ce
qu'il ne faut pas un référendum?
Vous avez défendu le référendum
d'initiative partagée.
- Yan Chantrel:
Je considère
que le référendum
d'initiative partagée
est une bonne chose.
J'ai défendu un texte
qui n'a pas été adopté,
mais le concept,
c'est de pouvoir donner beaucoup
plus la parole au peuple
et que lui-même
soit à l'initiative
de certaines mesures.
Ce type de sujet
n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour.
Quand on rencontre
et qu'on échange
avec nos compatriotes,
ils ne nous parlent
pas d'immigration.
Ils parlent de la santé,
du pouvoir d'achat,
du logement.
- Kathia Gilder:
On va finir
par une question politique.
Agnès Firmin Le Bodo a été nommée
nouvelle ministre
de la Santé en remplacement
d'Aurélien Rousseau,
mais selon Mediapart,
elle a fait l'objet d'une enquête
pour avoir reçu
20.000 euros de cadeaux
de la part d'un laboratoire
pharmaceutique.
Est-ce que sa nomination
était pertinente
comme ministre de la Santé?
- Yan Chantrel: Non.
Ce n'est pas pertinent.
Le président
de la République devrait
en prendre acte et lui retirer
sa responsabilité.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Merci, Yan Chantrel,
d'avoir été
le dernier invité
de notre émission en 2023.
- Kathia Gilder:
Merci à la régie
de nous accompagner.
On vous souhaite
de joyeuses fêtes.